BDM and the establishment they are
petrified of Elections why are they
petrified because every service says PTI
will get two-thirds majority the moment
there are elections a man who's known in
this country for 50 years had never had
one case criminal case just in four or
five months 150 criminal cases why to
get me out of the race out of 150 cases
they have come with two corruption cases
on one is of a charitable trust I've set
up you know Al-Qaeda University
they haven't shown how how I made any
money from it secondly is the stosh
which you must understand what those for
70 years the law in Pakistan is that he
went as a head of state you get gifts
from dignitaries or so on whether it is
you are a minister of general or
whatever it goes into the Tosh which
evaluates it then you have a chance do
you want to buy it all that is recorded
you cannot arrest an idea whose time has
come if you look at the poles the poll
ratings The surveys
ETI is 70 now no party has had such
popularity so this is madness what is
going on they're trying to um basically
kill democracy because you know by
killing the biggest or trying to crush
the biggest party in the country the
only Federal party in the country they
actually dismantling democracy without
rule of law countries you know don't
Prosper you don't have democracy so the
key to a a civilized society is where
everyone is equal before the law
and unfortunately Pakistan from its
beginning
as the law of the jungle